wand customization and sorting those
have been two of the biggest questions
by far among hogwarts legacy fans and
today as part of the back to hogwarts
event hogwarts legacy dropped some big
time news on how those will work in the
game so to start off they dropped an
absolute bombshell you can actually link
your harry potter fan club wizarding
world pottermore whatever you want to
call it you can link that account to
your wb account which will bring your
wand and hogwarts house into hogwarts
legacy and also unlock a few in-game
rewards more on those in a second i know
this is something that fans have been
asking for since i i mean i've been
making videos on this game for over two
years now and some of my very first
videos were about the top things that
people wanted to see in hogwarts legacy
and this is 100 something that fans
wanted to see and now we have
confirmation of it now i know a question
you probably have is what about the
patronus because the patronus is also
something that you can unlock on the
wizarding world website but no mention
of it here and i think it's safe to say
if they're not mentioning it then it is
not coming over now does this mean that
expecto patronum is not in the game i
don't think so i think there are some
ways they could do that and in fact i
mean if you think just about how many
different patronuses there are on the
wizarding world website that would be
incredibly difficult to program that in
so i would not hold your breath on that
one happening but the wands and the
house that alone is incredible to me now
another question people have been asking
is what if we don't like it what if we
don't want to link that or what if we
want the wand that we don't want the
house no need at all to worry there's
community manager chandler wood has
already confirmed linking your account
won't lock you into anything and
honestly you don't even have to choose
to link your wb account chandler wood
has already confirmed you do not have to
link the account so this is not
something that is required now the other
thing that this confirms is all of these
different wand types i mean it confirms
that they are having them in hogwarts
legacy if we can link this so all the
wand types all the one cores basically
everything on the wizarding world
website when it comes to wands to me
this says that it is going to carry over
in-game which is absolutely incredible
so how do you do this and what else do
you unlock by doing this well to start
you're going to need to go to
wizardingworld.com
legacy connect once you're there you'll
need to log in to your wizarding world
account if you don't have one of those
set up yet it is completely free to do
so when you set up that wizarding world
account you'll be able to go through a
series of questions a little quiz and
you will get sorted on the wizarding
world website you'll also do something
similar to discover your wand type as
well so once you're sorted and have
discovered your wand you'll go back to
the legacy connect website make sure
you're logged in and then you can link
this to your wb games account now if you
don't already have a wb games account
you can make one of those as well that
is also free and this account will
connect to steam it will connect to
playstation connect to xbox now as cool
as that is linking it to your house and
linking it to your one that is not the
only thing that you're going to get by
doing this you're also going to unlock
some exclusive in-game rewards the first
of which is an exclusive house fanatic
school robe and i gotta say these robes
are fire you guys now i feel like every
time they announce something like this
we always have 50 other questions and i
can hear you guys now you're probably
wondering is there a way to get all four
of these exclusive house robes now in
the announcement video chandler wood did
say an exclusive set of house themed
ropes so hopefully we just get the
entire set because you know people want
to do multiple playthroughs and they
want to be able to use these special
robes i guarantee that is a big question
right now hopefully we'll get some
clarification on that as well because if
not you already know people are going to
be making like four wizarding world
accounts trying everything they can to
get this to link up so they can get all
of the robes additionally you'll also
get the beaked skull mask which is
pictured here and looks kind of similar
to the skull mask that we saw in the
gamescom trailer and speaking of that
gamescom trailer there are so many
hidden details in there and if you
haven't watched the video on the right
side of your screen yet you've got to
check that out right now because there
are so many incredible details guys this
game is going to be amazing as always
thank you all so much for watching i'll
talk to you again soon